>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF HANNITY.
HERE'S A NUMBER I WANT YOU TO
REMEMBER.
61,312.
THUS THE NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS RELEASED INTO
THE COUNTRY AND JUST THE FIRST
THREE MONTHS OF ITS CONTROL OF
AMERICA.
FEBRUARY, MARCH, AND APRIL.
COMPARE THAT TO THE LAST THREE
FULL MONTHS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
TERM.
THE NUMBER OF MIGRANTS RELEASE
THEN WAS 47.
YES, WE WENT FROM A SIZE OF A
PING-PONG TOURNAMENT AT YOUR
LOCAL YMCA TO HARD ROCK STADIUM
WHERE THE MIAMI DOLPHINS PLAY ON
SUNDAY AND IT'S ONLY FOUR MONTHS
INTO THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO CATCH AND RELEASE IS BACK IN
A VERY BIG WAY UNDER
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
KAMALA HARRIS AND WHAT ELSE IS
THE ADMINISTRATION DOING?
THEY ARE PLANNING TO INCREASE
CAPACITY TO ACCOMMODATE MORE OF
THE MIGRANTS IF THEY DO CHOOSE
TO KEEP THE TANK, MEANWHILE THE
SO-CALLED BORDERS ARE
KAMALA HARRIS HAS LITERALLY HAD
NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT THE ISSUE
SINCE BEING PUT IN CHARGE JUST
ABOUT TWO MONTHS AGO AND HAVING
NEVER VISITED THE BORDER SINCE
SHE'S BEEN THE VICE PRESIDENT
BUT HER OLD FRIEND AND HOME
STATE GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM
ISN'T STAYING SILENT.
IN FACT, HE'S HAD SOME IDEAS ON
HOW TO SPEND HIS UNEXPECTED
BUDGET SURPLUS, MORE LIKE
GIVEAWAYS TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INCLUDING $105 MILLION FOR
HUMANITARIAN RELIEF, $50 MILLION
FOR ENGLISH CLASSES AND
$14 MILLION FOR LEGAL AID OFFER
MIGRANTS AND MIGRANTS ONLY AND
THEY WONDER WHY PEOPLE KEEP
COMING.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE FORMER
ACTING SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
CHAD WOLF AND THE CURRENT
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF ARIZONA.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, I WANT TO
START WITH YOU, WE'VE GOT THEM
SCREAMING AND BY THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS, YOU TAKE THAT
TRAJECTORY OVER A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE, A LOT OF THEM COMING TO
ARIZONA BUT MY QUESTION IS WHEN
THEY CATCH AND RELEASE SOMEBODY,
WHAT ARE THOSE PEOPLE IN ARIZONA
OR IF THEY MIGRATE UP TO NEVADA
OR ARIZONA OR IOWA OR WHATEVER,
UTAH, WHERE DO THEY SUPPOSED TO
LIVE, WHERE THEY SUPPOSED TO GET
ANY INCOME, HOW ARE THEY
SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES, WHAT ARE THEY SUPPOSED
TO DO THAT IS LEGAL AND LAWFUL
IN THE UNITED STATES?
>> JASON, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
HEARTBREAKING AND DESPICABLE
WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING, YOU WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT NUMBERS, 2 MILLION IS THE
NUMBER OF ESTIMATED PEOPLE JUST
THIS YEAR ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, THAT'S LIKE THE STATE OF
ALASKA, WYOMING AND VERMONT
COMBINED IN ONE YEAR.
WE KNOW THE CARTELS ARE
ENRICHING THEMSELVES, WE KNOW AS
A RESULT OF RECENT DISCOVERY IN
ONE OF OUR LAWSUITS AGAINST THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS AS A
RESULT THAT THEY ARE NOT PICKING
UP PEOPLE RELEASED FROM PRISON
SO YOU HAVE FELONS, ARSONISTS,
SEXUAL PREDATORS THAT ISIS NOT
PICKING UP, NOT DEPORTING HIM AS
YOU JUST SAID BEING RELEASED IN
OUR COMMUNITY SO THIS IS NOT AN
ARIZONA PROBLEM, NOT A TEXAS
PROBLEM, THIS WILL AFFECT EVERY
PERSON IN THE UNITED STATES,
JOHN F. KENNEDY PUT A MAN ON THE
MOON, BIDEN WILL END UP PUTTING
A FELON IN EVERYONE'S
NEIGHBORHOOD AND THAT IS HOW FAR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS CHANGED
JUST IN FOUR YEARS.
IT'S SHAMEFUL.
>> Jason: WHEN I WAS IN
CONGRESS, WE HELD HEARINGS
BECAUSE WHAT THEY DID WAS
RELEASE MORE THAN 65,000 PEOPLE
THAT WERE CONVICTED OF A CRIME
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
INSTEAD OF DEPORTING THEM, THEY
JUST RELEASE THEM BACK OUT INTO
THE HOMELAND, BUT WE ARE JUST
TALKING ABOUT THE FIRST FEW
MONTHS AND I HAVE SEEN
ABSOLUTELY NOWHERE ON THIS
ISSUE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, JASON.
THE LAST FOUR MONTHS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS SEEN THE
POLICIES HAVE FAILED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, HAVE FAILED THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND MOST OF ALL HAVE FAILED THE
MIGRANTS BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ENCOURAGING
THESE INDIVIDUALS TO TAKE THIS
DANGEROUS JOURNEY THROUGH MEXICO
AT THE HANDS OF THE CARTELS AND
THE TRAFFICKERS AND SMUGGLERS
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF DANGEROUS THINGS THAT GO ON
DURING THAT JOURNEY'S OF ACROSS
THE BOARD, THE POLICIES, THE
MESSAGING FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS ABSOLUTELY
FAILED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
MIGRANTS, AND OTHERS AND IT'S
CRAZY THAT VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
HAS NOT VISITED THE BORDER, HAS
NOT TALKED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS, THEIR JOB IS TO SECURE
IT EVERY DAY AND UNDERSTAND
THEIR CHALLENGES, UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY ARE GOING THROUGH SO
SHE CAN BECOME AN ADVOCATE FOR
THEM AND HELP THEM DO THEIR JOB
TO NEGOTIATE THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE IN MEXICO AND INSTEAD,
SHE WILL NOT GO TO THAT BORDER
AND I THINK THAT IS A DISSERVICE
NOT ONLY TO THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
DHS BUT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Jason: I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
THE DEMOCRATS TRY TO PLAY THE
COMPASSION CARD, AND THEY ARE
REAL FAMILIES BUT IS NOT
COMPASSIONATE TO ENCOURAGE THEM
TO MAKE THIS TREACHEROUS TRAVEL
NORTHBOUND.
WHEN I TALK TO BORDER PATROL
AGENTS, THEY ARE TELLING ME
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 60 AND 100%.
>> COME FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN.
I UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE WANT TO
COME TO THIS COUNTRY THAT WE ARE
A NATION OF LAWS.
THE REASON WHY SO MANY PEOPLE
ARE FLEEING COMMUNIST COUNTRIES
IS BECAUSE THE RULE OF LAW MEANS
SOMETHING.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF LAWS AND
WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING IS UNDERMINING IMMIGRATION
BECAUSE WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING
IS YOU HAVE FELONS RELEASED INTO
COMMUNITIES AND GOD FORBID THESE
DANGEROUS CRIMES, IT WILL AFFECT
US.
WE HAVE THE CARTELS MAKING ALL
THIS MONEY AND AN INCREASE OF
FENTANYL AND HEROIN COMING
ACROSS, THAT WILL POISON OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS, WHEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS TALKING ABOUT
SENDING $310 MILLION TO
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES TO
PROP THEM UP, THAT'S OUR TAX
DOLLARS AND PAYING $87 MILLION
FOR CONTRACT, THINK ABOUT THAT
NEXT TIME YOU HAVE TO WRITE YOUR
CHECKS, SO THIS ACTUALLY IS
CREATING A GREAT DIVISION IN OUR
COUNTRY, NOT SURE WITH THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
LONG TERM, I WILL TEAR THIS
COUNTRY APART.
>> Jason: I HAVE TEN SECONDS
LEFT, YOUR LAST THOUGHTS?
>> WHAT'S CONCERNING AT THE
BORDER IS BAD ENOUGH, BUT THE
FACT THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS ALSO
HANDCUFFED ICE FROM REMOVING
INDIVIDUALS WHILE THEY ARE HERE
IN THE INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY
IN THE PLAN IS TO LET THEM IN
AND THEN THE PLAN IS TO RESTRICT
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO
REMOVE THEM AT THE END OF TH